this tiny insect is called a
sharpshooter why you ask well
Sharpshooters fling their
pee and what's more they do it using
some pretty nifty physics called super
proportion and according to researchers
studying these Critters they may be the
only known animal that can do
[Music]
it
Sharpshooters feed by sucking up
nutrients from xylm the tubes which
plants use to transport water but xylm
fluid is about 95% water so to get
enough calories Sharpshooters need to
consume a lot and drinking that much
water means making a lot of
urine so flick
but why flick drops cardas fellow xylm
feeders and cousins of Sharpshooters
spray their urine in a much more
conventional way so why not
Sharpshooters well microct scans and
studies using high-speed cameras are
revealing exactly what's going on and it
turns out the answer all comes down to
size and
energy Sharpshooters are tiny and at
this scale water is for want of a better
word sticky Sharpshooters would risk
being engulfed in their own pee if they
didn't find a way to jetsen it but when
you're that small creating a jet of
water uses a lot of energy far more than
the Teeny Sharpshooters could muster so
they took a different approach the urine
is gently squeezed into a drop lip which
perches on hydrophobic hairs at the tip
of an appendage called a stylet the
Sharpshooters then pull back the stylet
like a spring and release it flinging
the drops with Incredible speed but the
droplets don't just move fast they move
40% faster than the stylet does this
phenomenon is called super propulsion
but how does it work well imagine a
diver bouncing on a diving board as the
board bends it stores energy then
releases it as it bounces back up if the
dive then times a jump at the right
moment they can make use of the energy
stores in the board to amplify that jump
traveling higher and
faster and it turns out something
similar is happening with the
Sharpshooter much like the diving board
tiny water droplets have the capacity to
deform and store energy in surface
tension as the stylet then moves it
compresses the droplet which then
bounces back time it exactly right right
and this bounce back amplifies the force
of the stylet and the droplet flies away
at a greater speed modeling has shown
that achieving this effect requires
extremely accurate timing too slow or
too fast and you risk the bounce back
actually counteracting the force of the
stylet slowing down the
flick and yet Sharpshooters appear
remarkably capable of hitting the right
Rhythm every single time saving them
energy and allowing them to keep feeding
super propulsion Is Not A New Concept in
the lab but the team behind this work
say that this is the first time it's
been seen in a natural system and that
similar approaches could be used to
remove unwanted water from devices like
smartphones or smart
watches all inspired by The Humble
[Music]
sharpshooter oh